et la migraine est une maladie neuro
vasculaire
re qui donne des céphalées sévères
prédominant d'un côté de la tête qui
sont de nature pulsatile est souvent
accompagnée de nausées de vomissements
et souvent une sensibilité à la lumière
et aux sons ce genre de modèles peuvent
durer plusieurs jours jusqu'à ce 3 jours
environ et ça peut être très des
bulletins
en fait la migraine c'est une maladie
neuro vasculaire très débilitante qui
donne des céphalées des motels très
sévère qui prédomine habituellement sur
un côté de la tête qui peuvent être
accompagnés d'autres symptômes comme la
nausée vomissements ainsi que la
sensibilité aux lumières et aux sons ça
peut durer jusqu'à trois jours et faire
en sorte que la tête qualité de vie de
la personne est très atteint l'arrivée
des anticorps contre le cgrp permettra
pour la première fois le potentiel de
mieux contrôler ses crises de réduire en
intensité et en fréquence les crises
migraineuses et possiblement redonner
une certaine qualité de vie à nos
patients que pour l'instant sont très
atteints ils sont pas capables et
sûrement de travailler ou de vivre leur
vie personnelle
donc j'espère que l'arrivée de ces
nouveaux médicaments vont leur permettre
de s'intégrer et d'être plus présents
dans leur vie
là quand on traite une maladie on veut
ça
acquis à la cause du problème et on a
maintenant des évidences scientifiques
solides que le crb est impliqué dans la
crise migraineuse